สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเเจอ
กันอีกแล้วใช่แล้วนะคะครูเรียมวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4
อืมเดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาค
คปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้ 15 น 1 นค่ะอู 141 นแล้วนะคะครูเรียม
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะสบายดีนะคะ
สบายดีค่ะครูหญิงตอนนี้ก่อนหน้านี้ไม่
สบายนิดหน่อยหืเป็นอะไรคะครูเรียมไม่สบาย
ปวดหัวปวดท้องปวดฟันปวด
ขามีหลายอย่างหูทำไมมีหลายช้อยจัง
เลยมีไข้ค่ะมีไข้ตัวร้อนอแต่ว่าไม่ครู
เรียมไม่ปวดหัวใช่มยคะ
ไม่ค่ะไม่ปวดหัวอ่าไม่ปวดหัวแต่ว่า
วีีดีโอนี้ครูเรียมน่าจะปวดหัว
ค่ะทำไมคะครูหญิงจะทำ
อะไรครูหญิงก็จะมาพร้อมกับปัญหาน่าปวดหัว
อีกแล้วนะคะมีคำถามมาเล่นกับครูเรียมให้
ครูเรียมต้องคิดแล้วก็อาจจะแบบออปวดหัวง
คิดไม่ออกอืหรือว่าต้องคิดคิดคิดเยอะเยอะ
จนปวดหัวไม่คิดว่าตอบได้อโอ้โหได้เลยค่ะ
งั้นเดี๋ยวครูหญิงก็จะมีเรื่องมา
เล่าก็เป็นเรื่องเนาะก็มาเล่านะคะแล้วก็
จะมีครูเรียมฟังจบแล้วเนี่ยก็จะมีคำถาม
ถามครูเหรี่ยมอืมีมีกี่คำถามคะครูหญิงคำ
ถามเดียวเท่านั้นค่ะครูเรียมง่ายมาก่าน่า
จะไม่ปวนหัวหลอกระดับครูเรียมแล้วใช่ๆอื
แล้วเรื่องเป็นยังไงคะครูหญิงฟังเรื่อง
เขาก็บอกว่าอุ๊ยนี่เป็นนิทานหรือเปล่าคะ
เนี่ยเบอกว่าเรื่องราวเนี่ยมันเกิดขึ้นมา
นานแล้วค่ะเมื่อก่อนเลยในสมัยที่แบบว่า
ยังมีพระราชาพระราชาก็คือในหลวงนะคะ
ในหลวงตอนนี้ก็มีพระราชาใช่แต่อันนี้ไม่
ใช่ประเทศไทยไงผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้ว่านี้
ประเทศอะไรนะคะอาจจะเป็นยุโรปหรือเปล่า
เนาะก็พระราชาเนี่ยนะคะก็มีลูกสาวอยู่ 1
คนใช่มมีลูกสาว 1 คนสวยมากนะคะลูกสาวของ
พระราชาส่วนใหญ่จะต้องสวยมากๆนะคะใช่ไม่
สวยมากก็ต้องแบบขี้เหร่มากเออแต่ไม่มีพอ
ดีเลยใช่มั้ยไม่มีไม่มีนะเคบอกว่าพระพระ
ราชานะคะก็มีลูกสาวลูกสาวเนี่ยก็อาจจะ
อายุซัก 17-18 และพระราชาก็เลยคิดว่าอุ๊ย
อายุ 18 แล้วเนี่ยต้องแต่งงานแล้ว
นะอือฮึอายุ 18 ต้องแต่งงานแล้วนี่อายุ
เท่าไหร่แล้วยังไม่แต่งงานนะคะเ 18 นี่
สมัยนั้นสมัยนั้นเออสมัยก่อนก็เออแต่งงาน
สมัยนี้ก็ 18 รู้สึกว่าเด็กมากหนังสือไม่
จบเลยอย่าว่าแต่แต่งงานเลยค่ะมีแฟนก็ไม่
ได้เออเนาะก็แต่
ว่าสมัยก่อนใช่มั้ยเวลาที่ลูกสาวของพระ
ราชาเนี่ยหรือว่าเราเรียกว่าพระธิดาหรือ
ว่าเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยนะคะเออเจ้าหญิงเจ้าหญิง
จะแต่งงานเนี่ยก็ต้องแต่งงานกับคนที่
เหมาะสม
กันเหมาะสมกันก็คือต้องเป็นผู้ชายเหรอคะ
อ่ะก็ต้องเป็นเจ้าชายหรือไม่ว่าถ้าไม่
เป็นเจ้าชายก็ต้องเป็นทหารซึ่งทหารของ
ของของสอเนี้ยนะคะเรื่องนี้เนี่ยในประเทศ
นี้เนี่ยเขาก็จะต้องเป็นทหารที่เป็น
ตำแหน่งที่เป็น
อัศวินอัศวินก็เดี๋ยวก็น่าจะรูปประมาณเย
เนาะเดี๋ยวูหญิงให้ดูนะคะนี่ใช่มั้ยเห็น
หรรือยังคะอืเห็นค่ะใช่นี่คือเจ้าหญิง
ใช่เนี่ยอัศวินนะคะอัศวินเห็นมั้ยพอเห็น
อัศวินขี่ม้าผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าต้องไม่
ใช่ประเทศไทยแน่ๆนะคะว่าประเทศไทยคนไทย
ไม่ขี่ม้านะคะขี่ช้าคแล้วก็เจ้าหญิงไม่
ใส่ชุดแบบนี้ด้วยใช่นี่เป็นเจ้าหญิงแบบ
ฝรั่งนะซินเดอเรลล่าสโนว์ไวท์อะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยอันนี้ก็ไม่ใช่เจ้าหญิงเลยนะคะเนี่ย
อัศวินใช่มั้ยคะถ้าไม่ใช่เจ้าชายก็ต้อง
เป็นอัศวินก็คือต้องเป็นทหารที่เก่งนะคะ
แล้วก็ต้องก็เลยต้องเหมาะสมเพราะว่าถ้า
เจ้าหญิงแต่งงานกับคนธรรมดาชาวบ้านขายหมู
ขายผักอ่ะอันนี้ไม่ได้ไม่เหมาะ
สมต้องแต่งงานกับคนที่เหมาะสมกันใช่มั้
เจ้าพระราชาเนี่ยก็เลยต้องจัดงานให้
อัศวินนะอัศวินหลายๆคนเนี่ยนะคะที่อยากจะ
แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิหญิงเนี่ยให้มาประลอง
กัน
อืประลองให้มาสู้กันเหรอคะโอ้ไม่ต้องสู้
ค่ะไม่ต้องสู้ระลองอันเนี้ยมาแข่งกันนั่น
แหละแต่ไม่ได้สู้กันเพราะสู้กันต้องตาย
ใช่ไหมมไม่เอาไม่ตายไม่ตายมาประลองก็อาจ
จะมีคำถามมีอะไรหลายๆอย่างเอ๊แข็งแรงมั้ย
ก็อาจจะประลองสู้กันก็ได้แข็งแรง
มั้ยฉลาดมั้ยคิวดีมยอ่าอาจจะให้วิ่งวิ่ง
ว่ายน้ำปันขี่ม้าแข่งกันเนาะประลองหลายๆ
อย่างอื
ซึ่งเวลาที่พระราชาประกาศออกไปว่าถ้า
อัศวินคนไหนคิดว่าตัวเองเก่งอยากจะมาเป็น
เจ้าบ่าวอยากจะแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงก็ให้มา
ประลองก็มีอัศวินอัศวินอัศวินหลายๆหลายคน
เนี่ยมาประลองเลยนะคะครูเรียมถ้าครูเรียม
เป็นอัศวินน่ะอยากจะแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิง
มั้ยล่ะถ้าเจ้าหญิงสวยก็คิด
ว่าอยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอืคิดว่าเจ้า
หญิงต้องสวยเพราะว่าคนก็ต้องพูดว่าเนี่ย
เจ้าหญิงเมืองนี้นะสวยมากๆเลยอัศวินก็แบบ
อู้สวยแล้วก็ยังได้เป็นสามีของเจ้าหญิง
อือนาคตก็จะได้เป็นพระราชาด้วยมั้ยใช่เออ
ถ้าเป็นครูหญิง่ะคะผู้หญิงจะไปประลองได้
มั้ยไปสิถ้าผู้หญิงเป็นอัศวินเก่งถ้าเก่ง
นะถ้าเก่งแต่ถ้าไม่เก่งไม่ไปกลัวเดี๋ยว
ตายแต่อัศวินส่วนใหญ่ก็ต้องเก่งเนาะเป็น
ทหารที่มาถึงเป็นอัศวินได้เออนะคะก็เลย
แบบพอมีพระราชาเนี่ยก็ก็เลยจัดงานประลอง
อัศวินขึ้นใช่มั้ยคะก็มีอัศวินหลายๆคน
เนี่ยที่มาแข่งกันที่แบบต้องผ่านด่านอาจ
จะมีด่านที่ 1 วิ่งโอเคผ่านด่านที่ 2
ว่ายน้ำผ่านด่านที่ 3 สู้กันใครแข็งแรง
ผ่านอ่าด่านที่ 4 อาจจะมีคำ
ถามทดทดสอบว่าอ่าสหมองดีมยเก่งมยแล้วก็
ผ่านใช่มั้ยคะก็มีหลายๆด่านที่อัศวิน
เนี่ยต้องแข่งแค่ฟังแค่ฟังก็รู้สึก
เหนื่อยแล้วตอนเนี้ยเออใช่เนาะแต่อัศวิน
เาอาจจะชอบก็ได้ไงทหารใช่มั้ยคะนั่นแหละ
แล้วสุดท้ายนะคะจากอัศวินทั้งหมดอาจจะ 100
คน 60 คนเนี่ยก็แข่งกันมาจนเหลืออัศวิน 2
คนสุดท้าย
เย้ดูรูปแต่ว่าเจ้าหญิงแต่งงานไม่ได้ไม่
เจ้าหญิงแต่งงานกับ 2 คนไม่ได้ค่ะต้องมี
สามีได้คน
เดียวก็เป่ายิ้งฉูบดีมั้ยคะไม่ได้สิเา
เป็นอัศวินครูเรียมเขาไม่ใช่เป็นเด็กๆอี่
ยังไม่ถึงคำถามนะคะครู
เรียมใช่มั้ยก็ต้องเหลืออัศวิน 2 คนสุด
ท้ายคิดว่าด่านทดสอบทุกด่านเนี่ยแข่งมา
เพื่อที่จะให้เหลืออัศวินจริงๆกี่คนก็ได้
แหละแต่ว่าทีเนี้ยเหลือ 2 คนสุดท้ายแล้ว
ใช่มั้ยคะก็จะต้องพระราชาเนี่ยก็ต้องคิด
ใครน่าจะได้แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอือืก็ต้อง
เหลืออีก 1 ด่านใช่มั้ยคะพระราชาเนี่ยก็
เห็นว่าอ๋ออัศวินเนี่ยขี่ม้าใช่มั้ยที่
ให้รูปอ่อให้ดูรูปเมื่อกี้นี้ใช่มั้ยคะ
อืมก็เหลืออัศวินเนี่ยอัศวินเออขี่ม้าสี
ขาวแล้วก็อัศวินบีขี่ม้าสีสีน้ำตาลมยสี
น้ำตาลหรือว่าสีดำหรือว่าสีดำเนาะใช่มั้ย
คะก็เหลืออัศวินเนี่ย 2
คนพระราชาเนี่ยก็เลยบอกว่าให้อัศวิน 2 คน
นี้เนี่ยขี่มาม้าแข่งกัน
อืง่ายมากให้ขี่ขี่ม้าแข่งกันไปที่แม่น้ำ
พระราชากับเจ้าหญิง
เนี่ยจะนั่งรออยู่ที่แม่น้ำอืพระราชาจะ
นั่งรออยู่ที่แม่น้ำให้ขี่ม้าแข่งกันง่าย
ใช่มั้ยคะครูเรียมง่าย
มากแต่มันไม่ง่ายอย่างนั้นสิคะครูเรียมจะ
ทำอะไรคะจะมีด่านเหรอไม่มีด่านค่ะแต่ว่า
พระราชาเนี่ยให้ขี่ม้าไม่ได้ให้ขี่ม้า
แข่งกันแบบใครถึงก่อน
ชนะให้ทำไมเพราะว่าปกติเนี่ยเวลาครูเรียม
ได้ยินว่าให้ขี่ม้าแข่งกันก็ต้องคิดว่า
ใครถึงก่อนถึงคนที่ 1 ชนะใช่มั้ยคะได้
แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงใช่ค่ะถ้าแข่งกันมันก็
ต้องเป็นแบบนั้นสิก็ต้องเอาคนที่อไปถึง
เร็วที่
สุดมันง่ายเกินไปค่ะพระราชาบอกว่าให้ขี่
ม้าแข่งกันไปที่แม่น้ำ
นะถ้าพระราชาเนี่ยนั่งรออยู่ที่แม่น้ำ
แล้วก็เห็นม้าของใครมาถึงทีหลัง
อืก็จะได้แต่งงานกับเจ้า
หญิงถ้าถึงก่อนก็ไม่ได้แต่งงานถึงทีหลัง
ถึงเป็นคนที่ 2 ได้แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอัน
นี้เป็นกติกาที่พระราชาบอก
อืใช่มั้ยอัศวิน 2 คนก็ต้องขี่ม้าแข่งกัน
แบบขี่ม้าแบบช้าๆช้าที่สุดเพื่อที่จะไป
ถึงแม่น้ำเนี่ยทีหลังเพราะว่าถ้าถึงก่อน
ก็คือชนะใช่มปกติเวลาเราถึงคนที่ 1 เนี่ย
เราจะบเย้ดีใจแต่กติกาของพระราชาเนี่ยถ้า
ไปถึง
ก่อนแพ้ต้องไปถึงทีหลังใช่มั้ยคะเพราะว่า
ไม่มีอัศวินคนไหนอยากจะไปถึงเป็นคนแรกไง
โหแล้วพระราชาไม่ขี้เกียจรอเหรอพระราชาก็
ต้องนั่งรอไงเพราะว่าผ่านไป 1 อาทิตย์นะ
คะผ่านไป 7 วันอัสวิน 2 คนก็ยังขี่ม้าไป
ไม่ถึงแม่น้ำออแสดงว่าเขาก็อยากแต่งงาน
กับเจ้าหญิงมากๆใช่เพราะเาต้องขี่แบบช้า
มากๆไงคะแล้วพอผ่านไป 1 อาทิตย์แล้วทั้ง 2
คนก็เลยรู้สึกว่าอันนี้มันอาจจะ
เป็นคงไม่มีใครชนะแน่ๆเลยอ่ะไม่รู้ว่าเรา
จะต้องขี่ม้าไปอีกนานแค่ไหนอือืเพราะว่า
อัศวินที่ขี่ม้าสีขาวก็ขี่ม้าช้าๆอัศวิน
ที่ขี่ม้าสีดำก็ขี่ช้าๆอัศวิน 2 คนก็ไม่
ยอมกันไงไม่มีใครไปถึงก่อนใช่มยอัศวิน 2
คนก็เลยบอกว่าก็เลยตัดสินใจนะคะลงจากม้า
แล้วก็แบบโอเคเรา 2 คนจะไม่แต่งงานกับ
เจ้าหญิงป่ะกลับบ้านอืใช่มย
แต่แต่เจ้าหญิงอ่ะก็แบบเออเจ้าหญิงก็แบบ
อ้าอัศวิน 2 คนนี้ก็เก่งแล้วก็หล่อแล้วก็
แข็งแรงทั้งคู่เลยอ่ะเจ้าหญิงก็เลยเดินมา
เจ้าหญิงก็เห็นใช่มมว่ารอ 1 อาทิตย์แล้ว
อ่ะอัศวินก็ยังไม่มาสักทีนึงอืเจ้าหญิง
เนี่ยก็เลยตัดสินใจเดินมาหาอัศวินทั้ง 2
คนแล้วเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็กระซิบใช่มั้ย
กระซิบกระซิบ
นะกระซิบก็คือพูดเบา
ๆกูกูเรียมกินข้าวหรือยังะอะไรนะอะไร
นะอันเนี้ยกระซิบไม่รู้ครูเรียมได้ยินือ
เปล่าไม่ไม่ได้ยินใช่มยกระซิบใช่มยกระซิบ
ที่หูหูของอัศวินทั้ง 2
คนเจ้าหงว่าอะไร
คะคำถาม
ค่ะเจ้าหญิงก็กระซิบพอเจ้าหญิงพออัศวิน
ทั้ง 2 คนเนี่ยได้ยินสิ่งที่เจ้าหญิง
กระซิบแล้วอัศวิน 2 คนก็กระโดดขึ้นมาแล้ว
ก็รีบขี่ม้าไปที่แม่น้ำ
เลยใช่มยจากที่อัศวิน 2 คนเนี่ยขี่ม้าแบบ
ช้ามากไม่อยากไปถึงแม่น้ำแต่พอได้ยินสิ่ง
ที่เจ้าหญิงกระซิบอัศวิน 2 คนเนี่ยรีบขี่
ม้าไปที่แม่
น้ำคำถามนะคะครูเรียมอเจ้าหญิงเนี่ย
กระซิบว่าอะไรครูเรียมคิดว่าเจ้าหญิง
กระซิบว่า
อะไรนักเรียนก็เหมือนกันนะจากอัศวินที่
ขี่ช้าๆพอได้ยินสิ่งที่เจ้าหญิงกระซิบบอก
รีบขี่ม้าอย่างเร็วอืเจ้าหญิงกระซิบว่า
อะไรทำไมอัศวินทั้ง 2 คนถึงรีบขี่ม้าไป
แม่น้ำเรียมถามใครได้มั้ยคะครู
หญิงสสำลักน้ำลายตัวเองนะ
คะไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้ครูเรี้ยมถาม Google
ไม่ได้นะคะครูเรียมต้อง
คิดเรียมขอไนเจ้าหญิงได้มั้ยเรียมขอ Line
ไคิดเจ้าหญิงไม่รู้จักไอการดนะคไอการ์ด
คืออะไรเจ้าหญิงไม่รู้จัก Line อ่ะไม่รู้
จักอืครูเรียมคิดว่าอะไรคิดว่าคิดว่าเจ้า
หญิงกระซิบว่าอะไรต้องกระผิดก็ไม่เป็นไร
นะคะสนุกๆต้องกระซิบอะไรสักอย่างที่ทำให้
อัศวิน 2 คนนั้นไม่อยากแต่งงานกับเจ้า
หญิง
อืแต่ว่าอ๋อเจ้าครูเรียมครูเรียมคิดว่า
เจ้าหญิงอ่ากระซิบอะไรสักอย่างนึงใช่่
มั้ยคะที่ทำให้แบบเอ่ออัศวิน 2 คนได้ยิน
แล้วแบบว่าฉันต้องชนะเพราะฉันไม่อยากแต่ง
งานกับเจ้าหญิงไม่อยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิง
อืใช่ๆออครูเรียมอาจจะอะไรไม่รู้เอ่ออะไร
ก็ไม่รู้แต่ว่ามันต้องเป็นสิ่งที่ทำให้
อัศวินเนี่ยไม่อยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอ๋อ
อะไรอ่ะไม่ใช่ค่ะครูเลียมสิ่งที่เจ้าหญิง
กระซิบเนี่ยแล้วทำให้อัศวิน 2 คนรีบขี่
ม้าไปอย่างรวดเร็วอ่ะก็เพราะอัศวิน 2 คน
อยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงนี่แหล่ะค่ะอยาก
เป็นคนที่ได้แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงแต่ก็รีบ
ขี่ม้าไปอย่างรวดเร็วแต่ว่าพระราชาบอกว่า
จะให้คนที่ขี่ม้าไปช้าที่สุดแต่งงานกับ
เจ้า
หญิงเห็นม้าเห็นม้าเห็นม้าของใครถึงที่
หลังคนนั้นได้แต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงเห็นม้า
นะไม่ได้เห็นอัศวิน
พระราชาบอกว่าพระราชาจะนั่งรออยู่ที่แม่
น้ำแล้วพระราชาเห็นม้าของใครมาถึงทีหลัง
คนนั้นได้แต่งงานกับเจ้า
หญิงเจ้าหญิงก็เลยกระซิบบอกอัศวินก็รีบ
กระโดดขึ้นมาแล้วก็รีบขี่ไปเลยแต่อัศวิน
ยังอยากแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอยู่นะเห็นม้า
ของใครมาเห็นทีหังเกี่ยว
กับครูเรียมคิดออกมนักเรียนคิดออกมยถ้า
นักเรียนคิดไม่ออกยอมแพ้ก็ได้นะคะ
นี่ไม่เหลือเวลาแล้วเลยอีก 2 นาทีตอนแรก
อ่ะเดีวจะตอบว่าเจ้าหญิงจกะซิบบอกว่าฉัน
ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงอะไรเงี้ยนึกว่าแบบเจะแบบ
รีบไปเพราะไม่อยากแต่งงานอืไม่แต่รีบไป
เพราะว่าอยากแต่งงานค่ะเพราะว่าเฉลยนะคะ
เฉลยเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยกระซิบว่าให้ 2 คนเนี่ย
สลับม้ากัน
อออ่าแบบนี้นะคะนักเรียน
ออใช่ไหมยอ่าให้อัศวินคนนี้อัศวิน a มา
ขี่ม้าของอัศวิน B อัศวิน B มาขี่ม้าของ
อัศวินเอพอไม่ใช่ม้าของเราเราก็อยากจะขี่
ให้ถึงเร็วที่สุดเพราะว่าพระราชาไม่ได้
บอกว่าเห็นใครใช่มยคะพระราชาไม่ได้บอกว่า
เห็นอัศวินพระราชาบอกว่าถ้าเห็นม้าของใคร
มาทีหลังอืคนนั้นจะได้แต่งงานใช่มั้ย 2
คนก็เลยพอไม่ใช่ม้าตัวเองก็อยากให้ม้าที่
ตัวเองขี่เนี่ยไปถึงก่อนอืเพราะม้าที่ตัว
เองขี่เนี่ยไม่ใช่ม้าตัวเองตอนแรกจะเป็น
เพื่อนกันอยู่แล้วเชียวใช่พอเจ้าหญิงมา
กระซิบปุ๊บไม่ต้องเป็นคู่แข่งกันต่อเพราะ
ว่าฉันอยากจะแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงอืตอนแรก
ที่ครูหญิงอ่านนะคะแล้วครูหญิงก็เลื่อนๆๆ
ๆๆลงมาไปอ่านเฉลยว่าเจ้าหญิงกระซิบว่าให้
สลับม้ากันผู้หญิงก็คิดสลับม้ากันทำไมอ่ะ
ตอนแรกผู้หญิงก็ยังงงงอยู่เลยนะทำไมต้อง
สลับม้ากันสลับม้ากันแล้วแล้วมันช่วยอะไร
อ่ะแล้วพอสลับม้าแล้วอ๋อก็เลยเข้าใจว่าพอ
ไม่ใช่ม้าของเราปุ๊บเราไม่ได้ขี่ม้าของ
ตัวเองเราก็อยากจะไปถึงคนแรกเพราะว่าไป
ถึงคนแรกเนี่ยแพ้ใช่มั้ยคะเพราะว่าเรา
อยากให้ม้าของเราที่คนอื่นขี่เนี่ยไปถึง
ทีหลังเหมือนเราแข่งกับม้าตัวเองอ่ะเอออื
แล้วสุดท้ายเก็ไม่ได้เฉลยใช่ใช่่มั้ยคะ
ว่าใครเป็นคนชนะใช่ค่ะเขไม่ได้เฉลยใช่เขา
แค่อยากจะให้เราเราคิดว่าเจ้าหญิงกระซิบ
อะไรทำไมถึงเปลี่ยนใจอัศวินที่ขี่ช้าๆ
เนี่ยกลายเป็นขี่ม้าเร็วๆอยากจะไปถึงแม่
น้ำเร็วๆเาอยากให้เราคิดไงอืแต่เจ้าหญิง
ก็ควรพูดควรกระซิบตั้งแต่วันแรกนะรอเป็น 7
วันได้ยังไงเ้าเจ้าหญิงก็ไม่รู้รู้ไงเจ้า
หญิงก็ไม่รู้ไงว่ามันจะใช้เวลานานขนาด
นั้นเจ้าหญิงก็บอกว่าถ้าเร็วมากไปกว่านี้
ฉันอายุ 19 ฉันจะแก่แล้วนะต้องรีบแต่ง
งานนะคะนักเรียนตอบถูกไนะถ้านักเรียนตอบ
ถูกก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้ว่านักเรียนอ้านัก
เรียนรู้ว่าเจ้าหญิงกระซิบว่าอะไรก่อนที่
ครูหญิงจะเฉลยนะก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้เหรอ
ใช่แต่วันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะต้องเจอกันใน
ดีโอถัดไปแล้วได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่นะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊าย
[เพลง]
บาย